alors pour commencer on va faire un
petit jeu je vais vous mettre une belle
image et faisait vous allez essayer de
trouver pour comment ces jeunes filles
sont restées inoubliable au niveau de la
création d'un du web
alors vous donnerai la réponse tout à
l'heure il ya une dizaine de jours on
fêtait les 50 ans de l'internet
c'est le 29 octobre 69 que deux
ordinateurs aux états unis deux
universités connect deux univers ce deux
ordinateurs et réussissent à échanger un
mot de sa lettre le mot login
c'est le début d'arpanet c'est l'ancêtre
d'internet il ya 30 ans cette année
juste 30 ans c'était au mois d'avril
tim bernard lee ingénieur chercheur au
cern à genève invente le web et le monde
ne sera plus jamais comme avant
alors le cern à genève
c'est ce grand centre de recherche à
cheval sur la suisse et la france ou des
savants du monde entier essaye de
comprendre d'où via l'univers comment il
a été créé peut-être un jour par qui il
été créé mais je crois que c'est pas
d'actualité alors vous l'avez tous
remarqué la notion de web et d'internet
se confondent
on ne fait plus la différence maintenant
entre l'application que l'on utilise le
web et l'infrastructure le réseau
l'internet
maintenant je ne dis plus jamais
j'achète
sur le web je ne dis plus jamais je lis
mon journal sur le web le pas ce que je
fais ça ou sur internet 1 donc ma
prédiction c'est que dans moins de dix
ans le mot web aura disparu alors je
vous propose quand même de d'essayer de
comprendre comment cette invention qui
est né dans les tuyaux obscur des
accélérateurs du cern
c'était application qui a été conçu pour
aider les chercheurs à échanger de
l'information a réussi à changer la
planète
alors si vous m'avez googleliser donc
vous savez que j'étais ingénieur au cnrs
plus partie pas plus particulièrement au
centre de calcul pas de ce qu'a dit
christian de centres de calcul de
l'in2p3 c'est l'institut national de
physique nucléaire et de physique des
particules et avec mon collègue wojtek
wolski qu on a mis en place donc le
premier serveur français
le quatre ou cinquième un serveur
mondiale c'est pas un exploit c'est pas
un exploit j'ai même dire c'était
difficile de faire autrement
en effet le centre de calcul de l'in2p3
travail de façon intime avec le centre
de calcul du cnrs à genève
donc on avait invité tim bernés relie
pour une conférence est ont levé demandé
de présenter son
son invention le web alors presque par
politesse
on a installé pour sa venue un serveur
web
on se demandait bien enfin
personnellement je me suis bien demandé
ce qu'on allait pouvoir en faire alors
ça a été d'autant plus facile que tim
avait développé le web sur un ordinateur
génial qui s'appelait le next alors moi
quand je parle du next je peux pas
m'empêcher de raconter un peu l'histoire
même en faisant très court c'était une
machine extraordinaire qui avait inventé
steve jobs ce pendant la période où il
s'était fait virer de chez apple ce next
il n'a pas duré très longtemps il a
servi au mois à inventer le web
disparu et il ne survit qu'à travers son
système d'exploitation que beaucoup
d'entre vous connaître connaissent ses
mac os 10 alors le web les fondements du
web
c'est quoi ces quelques langage pas
beaucoup on va dire 4 au langage dont 1
html
de par sa simplicité a vraiment été un
des éléments qui a fait que le web a
démarré bon ensuite au delà de ces
quelques langage il a fallu à lever
remonter un protocole pour faire les
échanges de données
ces fameux protocoles http coucou donc
au moins vous avez entendu parler et
puis un système pour référencer toutes
ces pages web qui se trouve sur la
planète
donc c'est le système des url et tout ça
sert un système qui permet de naviguer à
travers des liens hypertextes hockey
alors pourquoi ce web a fini par marcher
on peut vraiment se poser la question
c'était pas évident que ça marche ça ça
sautait pas aux yeux que ça allait être
quelque chose de merveilleux
alors ce qu'il a fait marcher c'est un
navigateur
l'alligator c'est ce que vous utilisez
pour aller sur internet et c'est
l'université de champagne aux états unis
qui a proposé qui a mis à disposition
gratuitement un nouveau navigateur
ce navigateur s'appelait mosaïque est ce
navigateur mosaic et il a amené deux
fonctionnalités nouvelles qui ont fait
démarrer le web
c'est à ce moment là que le web a
vraiment explosé alors c'est quoi ces
fonctionnalités très simple la première
c'était pas si évident que ça c'est le
support des images
bon au début le web c'était
essentiellement du texte avec des
espèces de liens violacé ceux qui s'en
souviennent
c'était pas très attrayant et mosaïques
supporte les images et c'est pas pour
rien je vous ai mis ses belles jeunes
filles
la légende veut que ça soit la première
image qu'ils aient circulé sur internet
en fait c'était un groupe de chanteuses
des employés du cern qui avait fondé un
groupe et qu'ils avaient appelé les
horribles sert net vous constaté
qu'elles sont pas si horrible que ça
alors tout ça c'est parce que le grand
projet du moment au cern
c'était le lhc le lhc c'est le large
hadron collider un accélérateur de
particules hors norme qui passe sous le
pays de gex enterré à 100 mètres sous
terre et qui fait à peu près 25
kilomètres donc mosaïque supporte les
images mais c'est pas tout il va
supporter quelque chose de beaucoup plus
fondamental c'est les formulaires en les
formulaires c'est quoi c'est ce qui va
permettre de faire une application sur
le web
et cette application vous allez la
télécharger dans votre navigateur
elle va vivre sur votre ordinateur que
pendant le
vous allez vous en servir alors c'est
quoi une application web
c'est par exemple c'est un site qui est
étrange dans lequel on fait des
transactions
typiquement par exemple le site de la
sncf sur lequel vous allez faire des
réservations
vous allez remplir plein de cases
choisir des horreurs et c'est donc une
application c'est ça est vraiment ce qui
est génial c'est qu'on fait un système
dans le web qui permet d'avoir des
applications que nos comptes sookie qui
ne pas installer sur son ordinateur
on a besoin d'une application on va le
chercher sur le web on s'en sert elle
s'en va c'est fini donc mosaïque va pas
durer très longtemps
ça a beau être le père des navigateurs
il était là avant la grande guerre des
navigateurs a qui ne laissera que les
quelques navigateurs frelons collègues
comme je sais pas firefox et chrome etc
internet explorer donc il va disparaître
très vite mais vraiment on peut dire que
c'est lui qui a lancé le web
alors cette application cette invention
avait vraiment une vocation planétaire
et ce qui est surprenant c'est une
petite la petite histoire c'est que le
serbe n'avait même pas pensé à la
protéger c'est assez extraordinaire
n'importe qui aurait pu voler les codes
du web
changer une bricole dedans dire le web
c'est moi et maintenant chaque fois que
vous mettrez un lien dans une page web
vous me verse heureux je sais pas quoi
un ado bitcoin par exemple ça n'existait
pas à l'époque mais bon peu importe
1 alors on est aux environs de 94 2000
les tuyaux de l'internet commence à être
suffisant on a des doutes on a les
outils les
gaffe à google apple facebook et amazon
vont arriver et vont s'emparer du web
vraiment google avec son moteur de
recherche va canaliser toute une partie
du trafic
facebook va arriver à créer son réseau
social amazon va phagocyter tout le
commerce international un
donc c'est gaf a ils vont récupérer
aussi toutes vos habitudes de navigation
c'est là vous allez devenir on va tous
devenir des documents au sens web du
terme google is able on va attraper nos
habitudes d'achat nos habitudes ce qu'on
va regarder nous habite notre équipe
spectacles etc
et cette denrée toutes ces informations
qu'on prend sur vous même c'est vraiment
l' or noir de l'internet
ça va être quelque chose d'éminemment
important alors en 2007
le smartphone d'arrivée et on va devenir
tous des hommes augmente et augmenter
avec cet outil en permanence au creux de
la main
alors cet outil petit à petit il va tuer
le web
doucement avec ses applications sur un
smartphone vous utilisez peu ou pas le
navigateur vous télécharger ces petites
applications que vous installez et à la
différence du web d origine ou avec un
navigateur vous alliez changer de
chercher des centaines d'avis
d'applications qui ne laisser aucune
trace
là vous installez des centaines
d'applications qui bouffent la mémoire
de votre smartphone ce qui fait qu'on va
vous le vendre un peu plus cher pour qui
et pour qui est de la place et et ses
applications
vous n'allez pas les chercher n'importe
où deux endroits
l'apple store google plaît
ça devient c'est quelque chose qui
commence à devenir un petit peu
inquiétant on donne tous ces grands
opérateurs de l'internet alors le web va
évoluer
on arrive de plus en plus à
l'utilisation de langage naturel
beaucoup d'entre vous comment savoir des
enceintes connectés donc ses grandes
oreilles de syrie alexa google qui
écoute en permanence que vous faites est
comme vous leur posez une question qui
vous répondent en langage d'un naturel
on va voir l'apparition des tchats
bottes
vous avez l'habitude quand vous
téléphonez à votre banquier vous allez
avoir un automate qui va s'interposer
entre vous et le conseiller que vous
voudriez vraiment à voir et qui va nous
enquiquine elles le plus longtemps
possible pour essayer de vous apporter
lui-même la réponse alors que vous vous
savez bien que jamais la rivera vous
donner la réponse que vous attendez mais
mieux on va faire maintenant des
personnages virtuels vous allez vous
adresser à une personne qui n'existera
pas un vraiment personne virtuel et
cette personne c'est mieux qu'à chaque
bottes parce que là elle va être capable
d'afficher des sentiments en gros quand
vous allez appeler votre banquier c'est
dans votre banquier que vous allez avoir
c'est ce genre d'automates et si vous
lui demandez quelque chose qui lui plaît
pas il aura un visage un peu fermé
triste comme si c'était votre vrai
banquet au contraire c'est voulu acheter
une assurance
il sera souriant on va de plus en plus
vers ce genre de choses on nous prédit
même
elon musk que dont vous avez entendu
parler prédit même d'implanter de mettre
des implants de renault au niveau de
notre cerveau pour qu'il devienne pour
que le web soit le périphérique de notre
cerveau ou alors peut-être l'inversé on
sait pas bon c'est pas pour demain mais
c'est quand même en 2000
20 que vont se faire des
expérimentations d'un plan sur le
cerveau ça marche ça marche déjà aux
pilotes des exosquelettes pour des gens
qui sont paraplégiques avec des implants
de ce type là l'idée c'est de mettre à
tout le monde alors le web c'est aussi
l'outil qui alimente des tonnes de
technologie je pense par exemple à
l'intelligence artificielle ou machine
learning
c'est des choses qui n'existerait pas
s'il n'y avait pas le web
et si le web d'engranger pas en
permanence des tonnes d'informations des
nouveautés comme la les blocs chaînes ne
peuvent exister que à travers le web
alors là blocs tienne c'est pas que le
bitcoin c'est une technologie émergente
qui permet de conserver des données de
les sécuriser et surtout de les répartir
sur le réseau alors ça c'est une
technologie intéressez vous à cette
technologie est là elle va bouleverser à
mon avis tous les métiers alors si les
physiciens n'avait pas inventé le web où
en serions nous aujourd'hui
alors c'est sûr on en serait presque au
même endroit parce que l'avènement du
numérique
c'était quelque chose d'imparables ça
devait arriver
alors vraisemblablement on n'aurait pas
eu de navigateurs et tout se passerait
travers les petites applications qu'on
met sur son smartphone donc on serait
déjà pour nos applications complètement
lié à ces grands opérateurs américains
il faut savoir que les services web que
vous accédez vous aller quelque part
sont pour la plupart du temps hébergés
sur les serveurs d'amazon 80% des
entreprises du cac 40 sont sûrs a w s
amazon web services et peut-être que les
20% ils sont dans le cloud de google ou
dans celui de microsoft
le web a été quelque chose qui a été
complètement captée par ces grandes
entreprises
alors si le mot web disparaît la
question qu'on peut se poser c'est
quelle liberté
il restera encore sur internet c'est
vraiment la question qu'il faut se poser
je vous laisse en compagnie de tim
bernard lee pour méditer cette question
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]